from CNN protesters interrupt Ted Cruz's
interview on The View do you guys see
this Ted Cruz is on The View and it was
disrupted by protesters and it was
really funny that people were saying
that it was the cat with the salad meme
because the The View women like Whoopi
Goldberg was screaming at the audience
to like stop yelling and Ted Cruz was
just laughing it's like having a good
time so so you have these climate change
protesters appearing on The View
they're screaming while Ted Cruz is
talking
and they're they're they're protesting
oil or whatever I don't know what group
they're with cover climate now they
yelled here's the best part we're 15
days away from the midterm elections
early voting is already happening and
the number one issue right now in
people's minds for the most part is the
economy and gas prices so when you have
a republican at on The View in front of
all these people and you're screaming no
more gas no more fossil fuels Ted Cruz
many should have been like well I assure
you if you've got Republican we'll make
sure there will be more of it and then
the prices will come down but think like
these activists I look my conspiracy
theory on this one is that they're being
they're being hired by Republicans
oh I don't know about that including the
soup can girls soup can girls uh
non-binary modules well sweet potatoes
apparently it's an heiress to the Getty
oil Fortune who's been providing some
funding to them and and so I'm saying
I'm not saying it's true I'm saying it's
conspiracy theory why right before the
midterms are anti-oil activists acting a
fool making the left look really really
bad and when gas prices are freaking
people out you know what I mean it's
just I'm not literally saying the
Republicans are paying them I'm saying
they may as well be all Republicans
should be clapping and cheering for this
to be fair we don't like the Republicans
never fight like right anyway and they
don't fight dirty like that that's
probably been one of our biggest
weaknesses so I I couldn't give them
that much credit for thinking that far
ahead they're literally screaming no
more oil like what are you going to be
using that and my favorite calling for
mass murder yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely they don't understand the
larger consequences if we get rid of I
mean we do understand the larger
consequences and they just don't care or
maybe no maybe they just want to get rid
of people they're consequentialists they
care
like they they care about the Earth and
not the people you know what I mean like
do I care about the the the the the
centipede that I step on as it's like
you're running towards me I'm like oh is
that a beat it's like I care to get rid
of it you know what I mean like do you
care about the Wasps you spray you care
in the sense that they they have alerted
you to their presence you don't like
them and now you're doing away with them
you know what you're saying I think that
we can have the same Comforts and
luxuries that we have now without fossil
fuels don't they they want to survive
what I'm saying is they think we can
have the same comfort as we do now
without fossil fuels if tons of people
die you see that you see what I'm saying
you know like when I see a wasp's nest
on my porch I care that is not a good
thing and so I spray them and the wasps
die so they care but not in the way
you'd think a human is supposed to care
about another human yeah my favorite
thing is seeing all the garbage left
after a lot of these climate change
rallies my second favorite thing was
recently seeing a video of these people
gluing their hands uh to the street and
then one of the ladies doing that glued
her hand and took toxic super glue and
just threw it down the drain right
afterwards with a sign that says we need
to protect the environment I mean these
people could be making legitimate
actions there are legitimate things that
we could do to start cleaning things up
especially in our environment especially
when it comes to holding multinational
corporations accountable especially when
it comes to holding China accountable
but they're not doing any of that their
their end goal is to essentially punish
everyone for for not paying enough taxes
to the government which is such an MK
Ultra mind control belief that is just
mind-boggling being able to sit here
saying these people think if you give
the government more money the weather is
going to be gooder that makes no sense
at all the funny thing is is that like
this is this is a picture of Lucas
there's a bunch look you Google search
garbage at climate rally and there's
just like thousands of photos absolutely
super glue like just them purchasing
super glue you're supporting the
petroleum industry like how many like
they don't realize how maybe they
shoplifted it the um probably but then I
mean throwing it down the sewer I mean
come on that's just they're also putting
their money where their mouth is by not
uh bathing
that's true and not having kids so true
or aborting them so it's like the end
result of leftism is it just won't exist
in 50 years I'm okay with that
kind of like I'm okay with people like
you know
I'm not okay with that no no no that's
terrible that's not no but what I'm uh
you know you want you want you want to
tell people that they can have uh
abortions and they can sterilize their
kids no I don't want anybody to have
abortions I think that's right but I do
think that if there's like a bunch of
people like running rough shot in North
Philly and cops are getting killed all
the time that fine let them go shoot
each other well I mean I suppose as an
issue of defund the police that's what
they've been arguing for so it sounds
like you're just saying you're you're in
favor of uh no I'm saying fund the
police fund it actually not there I mean
yeah they're not being crazy and that
they don't support defund the police so
put extra cops there I'm saying this
like look if if the end result of
let me put it this way
the left comes out and says women have a
right to choose to get an abortion okay
they say uh we're just watching the Ron
DeSantis Charlie christovate and uh
Ron asks Charlie Chris about child sex
changes and Chris keeps bringing up
abortion he doesn't answer the question
he says the abortion abortion a woman's
choice and it's like okay dude
if a group of people are burning the
country to the ground running through
the streets smashing Windows burning
everybody then they come out and it's
their political position they should be
able to abort their children and
sterilize them
I don't understand I I mean I do
understand why conservatives are mad
about it but it's also just kind of a
funny thing where it's like the people
who you think are evil and destroying
everything are also like ending their
genetic line and so it's just like
look I've tweeted this and I will say it
again one of the most shocking things to
me is that you can question fauci and
get banned from every platform you can
question the CDC and get banned from
every platform you can have a public you
could be a doctor who contributed to the
invention of mRNA and they ban you but
if you come out on Twitter
several times and say consider spaying
and neutering your children to save the
planet nobody cares not a single hit
piece no criticism no jokes no mockery
you can say please please abort your
kids there's too many people already not
not a single thing they it just it's
it's shocking me that
I just feel like that should be like
cancel culture worthy to come out and be
like you should abort your kids and
sterilize them they should be like you
you stop but then no no they cheer for
it and they're the ones who pretend to
be the champions of the poor when they
think it would be better to be dead than
poor Stacy Abram said abort poor people
they literally say that I was doing I
was doing a one-on-one video and we I
was debating some guy on the street in
front of like the Supreme Court and he I
said your argument there is that
um it's better it's better to be dead
than before and he goes yes that's
exactly what I'm saying I was like like
I didn't even know what to say I just
looked at him like you can't be serious
like what's the end result if they they
all start to sterilizing their kids and
getting abortions
I mean in 50 years they're gone kill
enough people that there won't be poor
people no no just just liberals no right
he's talking about like what I'm saying
is these people it is two this is the
crazy thing it is politically correct to
say
that the left should be allowed to abort
their children and sterilize their
children
how was that that sounds like
nightmarishly genocidal but for some
reason it is a political position held
by democrats
it's trendy according to the agenda and
narrative that they're trying to push on
everybody and uh yeah I mean you could I
mean according to who you talk to Mary
you could you could take out a lot of
poor people especially if you're talking
to individuals like you know Bill Gates
and all these other people who are
pushing this larger agenda against
everyone else specifically he wants to
take them out in Africa not in the west
but and in India too he's doing a lot of
projects there as well it's not
genocidal because they've dehumanized
that right like they say it's a clump of
cells or it's not it's not legitimate
but their own kids I know I'm not saying
it's right no I mean like sterilizing
their kids too I didn't hear that well
yeah they're giving they're they're
they're they're giving puberty blockers
and Other Drugs which are something
completely different like that's like
Munchausen Syndrome that is what mothers
are doing they're trying right sure and
for whatever is a bunch of different
reasons for abortions the point is both
result in the left erasing themselves
from from yeah so why should we complain
well they're they're so look because
children are the battleground of this
whole world school choice what do you
want to call it then school choice is
the battlefield so if if the argument
right now is it is politically correct
to to allow people to abort their kids
and sterilize their kids and that is
what YouTube says is the right thing to
say conservatives don't do it liberals
do do it
then okay well all right there you go
you get what you wanted in 50 years
there's no leftists but there's some
intrinsic morality that's there like you
can't go to the Pearly Gates of Heaven
and look at God and say Hey you know I
didn't do anything to stop it because it
would erase all leftists and I was happy
about that like you're trying to live
with your own Consciousness I think
that's where the Republicans I I
understand comes in with that and I I
understand conservatives are desperately
trying to save even the people they
really don't like it's it's it's a
fascinating phenomenon my point is just
that and they're happy it is they're
happy to kill us like let's not I mean
they're running look at the guy in in
Florida who just beaten look at uh Aaron
Danielson but but no my point is is not
uh to say that Republicans should you
know issue morality and ethics and and
let horrible things happen to kids it's
that the machine itself is destroying
itself The Establishment is destroying
itself with its own policies and the end
result is either going to be an Islamic
world or just a conservative religious
uh um abrahamic world of some degree I
was saying that earlier this morning
because all of these factions are all of
a sudden like attacking themselves like
the feminists are getting mad at this
LGBT trans kid agenda or women taking
over sports but the funnier the funnier
one is the Muslim Community they've been
more outspoken especially about the like
transitioning and the stuff and LGBT
agenda being in their schools all of a
sudden things that they wouldn't report
on especially in the UK about all the
grooming gangs and stuff all of a sudden
there's a grooming gang crisis and and
it's I really think it's because they've
been speaking out more about about the
trans agenda and the LGBT stuff in in
the schools because they won't have that
they are totally incompatible and it
also then it breaks down these like
Coalition building that the left is
trying to do
I I to me I think it's important to
fight for everyone even the deranged
lunatics and the leftists I think
everyone's important we are all a part
of humanity and that's kind of my like
hippy-dippy kind of world view the way I
see it but but also in a larger
perspective I think we have to
understand we're also facing a major
population crisis Elon musk's likes
likes to talk about this a lot uh it's
happening very severely in China right
now but in the United States and
particularly in Europe we're seeing the
decline of the current civilization of
the current population there to drastic
levels where soon there's not going to
be enough people to repopulate and with
that comes major uh crises towards our
entire infrastructure towards our our
entire economic system towards our
entire way of life so just just on that
own population crisis we need to fight
like hell so there are more lives in the
future to make sure that there's not as
much chaos thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm them and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there